[Music]
foreign
briefing for Wednesday May 3rd I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
Marissa Mayer is the former CEO of Yahoo
an early employee and first woman
engineer at Google and now the CEO and
co-founder of sunshine sunshine is a
startup that builds apps to automate
everyday tasks and helps people manage
their contacts it does this in part by
using artificial intelligence something
mayor who has two degrees focused on the
subject knows a lot about
during the Wall Street journal's future
of everything Festival she sat down with
wsj life and work coverage Chief Nikki
Waller to discuss Ai and sunshine here
are highlights from their conversation
you were interviewed a while back and
you had a great quote and you said if
technology can drive a car how come it
can't organize my contacts or make
scheduling easier it's a great
observation I think a lot of us feel the
same way well if we we've talked to a
lot of different people in terms of how
their day-to-day goes and if you ask
people you know when was the last time
you wanted to do something with someone
or for someone and why didn't you a lot
of times it's just because it's too hard
so for us we're starting with contacts
we have aspirations of what we want to
do in terms of going on to help people
and manage groups more easily events
lots of different kind of everyday
mundane tasks and how does AI play into
this
sure well AI is obviously having an
incredible moment and generative AI is
is a big part of that in our world just
like there's a lot of different things
that have human judgments and the need
for human judgments and I think people
haven't really thought about how do you
apply AI to these everyday tasks like
scheduling like contact management we
actually just implemented uh two nice
enhancements that involve AI uh just
last week one is looking at profile
pictures different pictures but you can
tell that it's the same person can we
actually deduplicate based on that and
business similarities right when you're
trying to basically in an automated way
organize someone's contacts people write
their company names lots of different
ways and so you know is it Facebook or
is it meta and actually being able to
take Ai and say okay we can train a
model over time and for the big cases
it's easy just to special case them but
if you really want to do it purely you
can actually do build a really good
model with AI that does a much better
job than people and takes a lot of that
mundane yes these are the same work out
of out of it and you know it it's so
interesting to hear about this how do
you get users who are so so part of the
way that Sunshine works is by ingesting
your contacts and even potentially
getting access to your email how do you
persuade users to sign on who might be
wary of privacy or or handing over data
well we do have a privacy pledge we
really believe very firmly that people's
contact data is obviously incredibly
personal and private and people are
really guarded about it so we it belongs
to them and that's our view we're just
simply helping to organize it so that
said I will say there's a lot of people
I have I've now talked to several
thousand people and I haven't met one
where they're just like I'm great my
contacts are in perfect shape
um I have I have no need for any help
here
um because you know usually everyone has
a different kind of mess but you've got
people who have first names no last
names lots of misspellings based on
meeting people at conferences people
generally have if they realize they want
help with their contacts they're usually
pretty happy you know it's undeniable
that the tech sector right now is more
anxious than it has ever been probably
at just about any point in his history
how is it being a Founder in this
environment right now
uh well I will say it definitely
stretches you uh there's always a lot of
different demands when I've talked with
other Founders the number of things that
you have to go from knowing nothing
about to being an expert in that may or
may not be related to your core business
is high right we all had to become you
know we all had to have a crash course
in epidemiology then we all had to have
a crash course in you know insured
deposits and banking earlier this year
and so the number of times when you're
just like wow I didn't know anything
about this on a Wednesday and by next
Monday I need to know it well enough to
make good decisions well enough to talk
about it with our company on the on the
flip side I think that given what's
happening with AI at the moment I think
there's a lot of there's just so much
idea generation right I saw an
interesting Tweet back in February where
everyone's like wow like there's been
very few products in history that have
caused you know pretty much every
founder to reconsider their product and
business plan in the first 60 days of a
calendar year and so I think that
um you know that it's been it's been a
fascinating time and I think we're going
to see a lot of interesting change in
progress quickly how has that affected
Sunshine because you've been around for
a couple of years in stealth mode and in
beta and it's you have an AI startup
essentially is that causing more people
to call you are you getting more inbound
what's the conversation like uh I think
that there's just a lot of excitement
what can we do with it what what what
works well what doesn't work well right
everyone's up you know our business name
similarity actually uses open AI API so
it was actually really fun for the
engineers to experiment with how much
data do you need how much data do you
need to make the model to perform at
this accuracy or at that accuracy and so
I think you know overall there's just
been a ton of excitement in terms of
what of what can be done
you know you've always been passionate
about the consumer web and it feels
right now that a lot of consumer web
applications end up tethering us to our
phones more rather than liberating us is
there a way that AI or even apps like
yours can make us less dependent on our
phones I think both sunshine and AI can
make us less dependent on our phones you
know we're all just spending too much
time on our phones and people you know
and especially there's times there's
another agreement there's times when
it's a lot when they're you know in when
it's merited but there's also times
where you're like wait like I shouldn't
have to be you know messing with my
calendar or messing with my contacts
fumbling around looking for a number it
should just work uh and kind of taking
that craft away is something that's
that's really important and I think that
AI is going to take away a lot of
mundane tasks uh from from people and
hopefully free people up to spend more
time creatively spend more time with the
with the people they want to spend time
with
um and just more meaningfully on
relationships as opposed to all of the
logistics Marissa you have two degrees
in artificial intelligence we're all
here to talk about the future
um with generative AI how's this going
to shake out are you are you a utopian
are you a pacifist where do you think
it's headed
um I think you have to be somewhere in
between uh I think that I I think I
personally think I'm obviously a tech
Optimist and so I think that there's
going to be amazing things that come out
of the generative AI movement and AI in
general that's why I've been so
interested in my whole career I don't
think you can just go blindly into
developing AI
um I I think there are some dangers
there that said overall I'm hugely
optimistic about what it can do for for
people and for Humanity Marissa thank
you so much
um they Club half of the audience and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]